beim fenzl nehme ich hier das ventil
auslese
immer vorsichtig
sehr gut sieht das hier
nicht so viel und immer schön bemessen
grünen weg gibt es aber auch für später
shyne trocken schleudern
ausrutscher wieder belächelt und
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys wels
das kann man nämlich nach dem kochen
landab schleudern und dann kommt es hier
das ergibt sich also salz königin aber
ausgelacht weil ich immer so viel nach
noch schön drauf geben und ihr seht
schon abgelöst entweder nimmt ihr
wir wollten eigentlich grad nur
salz aber es schmeckt immer gut ja mein
direkt mit in die pfanne
mittagessen für uns unseres team machen
gemüsebrühe oder in dem wasser
schon mein fenchel der ist immer so ganz
ich finde das ist ein rezept das ist
frisch der liegt schon ein paar tage im
und dann haben wir gedacht nee kommt
schön mit anbraten
dann hast du kleinen shorts aufnehmen
kühlschrank das macht aber nix ich nehme
einfach schnell und ja flott gemacht und
eindruck ist fertig also wirklich
man könnte die knoblauchzehe da zu
und dann wird aus einem schnellen
hier die braunen stellen einfach weg und
perfekt und wenn ihr wollt macht ihr da
ihr könnt ja wirklich jedes gemüse mit
braucht schon alles sehr 1 liter
pressen dann müsste es ja auch nicht
brokkoli eintopf auflaufen doch wird ein
reinpacken was euch gut schmeckt alles
jetzt noch den käse drauf aber ich werde
kann den rest seien einfach klein
fehlen
war für ihn klar
den erst auf dem teller mit anrichten
großes rezept also gibt es ein rezept
schneiden und
gemacht dass videos gar das zu lange ihr
was ich hier auch auf den teller
und dann kommen da direkt die nudeln
video für euch heute gibt es wie gesagt
hier einfach nur beachten da unten
könnt es gern ausprobieren die rezepte
anrichten das ist das fälschen können
was schnelles fürs mittagessen oder
rein und ihr könnt jetzt auch reis
dann kann ich hier als nächstes direkt
findet ihr wie immer in meiner app die
dieses kleine dreieck wegschneiden das
abendessen bestehend aus einer
dazugeben oder bulgur zum beispiel aber
super dann würde ich sagen you tat darf
wird übrigens hat endlich endlich
die brokkoli röschen abtrennen und die
ist nämlich echt zu hart und den rest
hackfleisch brokkoli laut pfanne mit
schreibt gerne probieren legen gern
ich finde diese kleinen griechischen
überarbeitet und dann kommt bald die
könnte einfach in feine scheiben
gebe ich so im ganzen mit rein und den
nudeln die sind echt lecker und die sind
bisschen fenchel und nudeln und wenn ihr
schneiden mit gebraten und dann
community funktion endlich rein die
hallo
block brokkoli urkunden und dem brokkoli
also und was ich hier noch dazu geht weg
speicherfunktion ihr könnt dann euch
so schön und ich finde die konsistenz
das ganze vegetarisch oder vegan
zubereiten wollte einfach hackfleisch
immer da waren sind deswegen gebe ich
strunk den schäbig und kann ihn noch
rezepte hin und her schicken und das ja
sagt wenzel grund und unseren lieblings
weglassen denn der eindruck schmeckt
die dateien
fein würfeln und dann habt ihr wirklich
käse das ist ja der dass 60-prozentige
alles schon seit zwei jahren in planung
auch so schon richtig gut und wäre jetzt
aber wir machen ja immer alles selber
auch so gar keine reste die
ja ja das ist halt halt schon richtig
einfach zutaten aus dem kühlschrank
hier und ohne große agenturen alles und
weggeschmissen werden sondern verwehrt
genommen die da waren deswegen ein
das ganze gemüse mit nun muss man eben
deswegen hat das hat jetzt ein bisschen
schöner grüner eintopf mit nudeln ich
richtig liege ja ich meine gute als 60
dann schön salzen und pfeffern
wissen dass der brokkoli strom kein
gedauert aber so langsam kommt also
verwende dafür wie gesagt hackfleisch
prozent an man muss ja nicht was weiß
bisschen wie sage dann bisschen holz
nutzt die app auf jeden fall gerne und
habe ich jetzt 250 gramm rindfleisch 500
ich wieviel jahre ich finde also es
sich ist außen also gerade hier die
jetzt auf zu salzen up display wenn die
schreibt nur ein feedback zum rezept und
schmeckt auch ohne den käse aber ich
schale aber wie gesagt da können da
gramm brokkoli eine stange porree eine
wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal
find der käse der top deshalb
camera raw 6
einfach das drumherum so ein bisschen
knoblauchzehe 2 fenster knollen ich habe
war ich hunger ich bin
weg schälen und das innere schon würfeln
und ich gebe jetzt hier noch oregano
hier diese krita racky nudeln und zwar
und man könnte jetzt auch noch
heiß ich trage jetzt einfach das salz
dazu ulrike
gratinieren wenn man möchte in diesem
sind es diese griechischen nudeln etwas
weg irgendwie haben uns angewöhnt immer
ofen überbacken vielleicht am nächsten
und wird den deckel verschließen
aus dem bild zu laufen man muss immer
käse da könnte schafskäse nehmen oder so
tag weil ich finde sowas schmeckt frisch
was mitnehmen in salz und käse die
immer perfekt wurde am nächsten tag
es kocht jetzt schon auf dann stelle ich
einen hirten käse dann nämlich jetzt so
ein rädchen ein bisschen in den 250
könnte man so mit käse durchgezogen und
den herd herunter auf mittlere stufe und
gramm natürlich olivenöl zum anbraten
shaker vielleicht damit schafskäse oder
lass das gericht einfach so lange garen
etwas salz und pfeffer kräuter nehme ich
bis die nudeln sind denn der brokkoli
gleich noch dazu da gucke ich gleich in
mit mozzarella
darf er ruhig noch bissfest sein und es
die schublade was ich so dahab und
dauert jetzt ungefähr zehn minuten
wasser natürlich zum aufkochen das war
fertig
es schon und was ihr dafür braucht ist
wahnsinn das ging schnell
ein schneidebrett messer kochtopf das
ach komm ich noch dazu
war's mehr braucht ihr nicht und ihr
könnt das ganze entweder im topf zu
das passt du machst du fleischgericht
bereiten als mord oder ihr könnt später
sogar nochmal überbacken mit diesem käse
das entscheiden wir gleich spontan die
aber hast du mal was bei mir gegessen
gucken mal
zuerst werde ich jetzt das olivenöl in
was erhalten wird er liegt da ich glaube
einem topf erhitzen und wird hier das
das zieht immer nur so brutal aus okay
hackfleisch schön krümelig anbraten und
an 18 dieser kameras er hat schon mal
in der zwischenzeit die pure stange ich
was versalzen das geht erst da wie einem
salat rasse und das ist schon wahnsinn
mach's da immer so dass ich den porree
das zu einem mini zutat als ist so als
einfach im ganzen erst mal waschen aber
wenn da so jetzt das rein machst einfach
der ist ja oft sehr sandig im innern und
kaputt ein essen ja absolut unzureichend
dann schneide ich den und was stehen
dann noch mal geschnitten dann bekomme
durch man schließen dass denkt salz
ich nämlich wirklich überall im sand
raus medien
[Musik]
[Gelächter]